but let me tell you what was maybe the
hardest part about the whole like Trump
thing and stuff it was when you know
what it's like to be a workaholic and in
when the Trump thing happened I was in
the middle of a 50 City Tour and after
the photo all 25 of the remaining shows
were canceled due to bomb threats to the
theaters and the fact that the phone
didn't ring for six years was like the
hardest thing on my mental health just
to go from I'm going on the road today
I'm going to do a TV show today I'm
going to do a commercial like whatever
I've been doing all these decades to
have that just stopped but also to have
the country loathe you like loathe you
well do you really think that that
you're saying the country but obviously
we are in a very divisive state so if
you're reading or putting yourself in
front of the loathing then which is not
healthy I would imagine I wasn't doing
that it was the silence that I couldn't
escape and like I said you probably had
you probably had a lot of support too I
did I had some good friends I will say I
lost about 75% of my friends and they
never came back and so I also okay I
know I'm laying it on thick but I also
became addicted to prescription pills so
I also tried to take my life and I was
in a 5150 cych hold for three days at
Cedars and so I actually even though I
was a pill girl I go to AA meetings on
Zoom every day and I've made a lot of
friends through AA so I've been lucky
about like getting some nice friendships
going but that's why we were joking
before about the art of
conversation I kind of just live for
that now I just want to like really talk
to people I have these Salon lunches and
dinners where I make sure everybody
doesn't even bring their phone to the
table like after going through all that
stuff I just want to like hang out with
people and laugh and talk about stuff
I'm still I'm not as much of a News
Junkie cuz I had to walk away from the
cable news it was making me too nuts but
you know I keep up on stuff why did you
lose friends why did you lose 75% of
your friends because because remember I
would imagine a lot of your friends were
not Trump supporters no but by the way
some were you know I I look I was very
dear friends with the late great Suzanne
Summers Thigh Master if you don't
remember and you know she definitely was
a hardcore Trumper and some of the folks
I met through her like some of my older
friends you know were trumpers and um I
mean there was one guy that my husband
and I had just taken a dinner about
three years prior and he was on the
board of directors of CBS and he wrote
me this letter that was just you should
go to Oval Office and get on your hands
and knees and beg for forgiveness and
tell Trump you were stupid and you
deserve the blowback but beg him for
your career back and this guy was on the
board of directors for CBS he's now
passed away but I'm just saying like I
tried to stay away from all the bad
stuff and the blowback but like I said
the fact that your phone phone isn't
ringing and your tour is cancelled you
know and many theaters made statements
saying I wasn't welcome back at the
theater ever again and stuff now many of
them have since changed their tune which
is great but the turnaround really just
happened and I have to thank the Mirage
because as you know from doing Vegas off
and on all these years you know Vegas is
is not edgy like people think like it
may be a naughty City but it's Middle
America that's going to shows in Vegas
largely and so my first show back was
last June which is now just a couple
months ago and I sold out then they
booked me for one show in August I sold
out and hence you know with a mutual
friend called a manager I got a manager
then an agent and this tour came
together three weeks ago so I am
congratulations because I feel like
there's concrete proof that things are
finally turning around like I'm you
survived it I mean I don't think I don't
think a lot of people could go through
what you went through it was rough it
was rough cuz you know you also you I
also like have to get good at talking
about it because for a while I would
really bristle if anybody had a question
and now I I realized like the great Jane
Fonda was like this is going to be on
your Tombstone kiddo and she's
right